[Music]
zo en brings the talk about this idea of
er determine based on shorten somet
ing that would be working nine pages
by kennels wenders new resea
ch project at stand for the penci
so best I in the barcode for the they
see also the right point to a while
now time to think about
easy to use programming models for brush
there is for paulo machines for big data
and if is punishable action it i more
water again list
the pain on the point and he wanna make
your boat  composer images you live
where the action make voice is an oil that
where he was talking about sparta there is
also the 6 trajectory two lines of code to
do this kind of euro where there
prepare in early sink into my
apps build reaction form corpse quarter
makes  it on your phone and basic
this asian studies tempo decision is
that the de mee no way people actually
products weddings after really the om is
new at can posing stuff that
already exists out there that can je
n  odig om nature of stuff' creates have be
strong and composing things thereby
became by other people and that
really indicates the the most important thing and
that's why i van en spark you know
people like said you can write now
wc ok minsk war stringvar  something
like pointing to 4000 lines or short of
three of more excited when they can bring
colleagues online so we went to
live focus notch and this is
fun anyway and it's kind of either never
you can you can crm you so you see
things like this  zo like enamel food
are super easy to use you
can just import and i think you want and
you also see things like this where
basically when drink programming you
just
searching toe stack overflow for example
of a lively
that indicates something and actually de  this
is not a job
so just a plank in microsoft visual
studio in the sunshower asia searchsearch
stack overflow in addition tierpark this
is the real thing iphone it catches the
plugins pa  ge and in that of comes the
grift and food stolen from so much in
action so that is hope the program
is
well that is the belly can that would type
her product also well injury also out in
how do they do also determine programming
what is glory oil  big depa is
derksen livorno will i designed with
composition and mind emojis to be the
get some jump dan dat was super hard
liked building a grab index igoogle there
something like that and it was awesome
just a good and after high the ballot
programs week if you  can call map
and reduce their jeff tino from esprit
cool
but they were two things that make them
a second fish infarcten lee camp oozing
large aplication are gilly products on
the first prize that there beautiful di's men idea
of specialized de student systems for each
tinky when  do you when
antiquarian maybe you something like a
grammar dat google or high for impala
you when the machine learning maybe
some eduardo paes your thing thing would it
right gr  aph labo
google hey this such a graph processing
system prego your mind your ideal gus basic
details don't sleep one hour
so so already can another
MP you throw the ghost
rider program that composite or you can't
allow
xvr of the student  systems and then the
second thing is even if you manage the
thereby seas us all the things that
compound and to
whack is expensive deterink is super solos door de cda
between two library cao's like saying
you call hive and then you call me loves
to do machine  learning you got there we
the tour finals so that think bet on
those locks rider detail details the feed
and by Noordermaat function after and the
so sorry ran one of the pokémon pico's
if you forget to import for my and
stuff you just get weird there hangs
so so this is kai or the the sticks out of
the boat we are and in spark of oil
die who when can your favorite
game blood and give you this
unified an engine and dpi you that most
produc  at the disposal of software I am of
your combine libraries' again and again by
people of diploma so we can the
two-piece as the general engine which
can just to move the strypes of
processing and understanding and then the
composable lydia and we have
dysfunctional ep  iron economy
wi-fi things it is to be a collection of
object and things right machine learning
and graphite rust function you call on
the is the study recollections so that we
scan of south park becomes
so in the stalker when branches [ __ ]
mid-level depiano this it the  box this
work outfit from which the pit french and
then action when talk about keep
his house inside folding detection
liner thing angry and spark and outsider
van in some really interesting be so
in spark the structured ep house out came
out in a while they be coming out  over
the past two years but really did they
find the final nights into porno have
much more powerful weer of composing
light breeze than the original epa en
third la  bels and really cool
optimizations and things you can do to
just would get before and then this
world by jack from stanford is an
attempted your uneven nice general
provided or at the time actually means the
tiger in single machine workflow engine
already at the targeting
paulo hardware i like  the way you and
things right address bar and wilder map
where the traders immediately die sticks
so if you look at this mark epa original
epa was so now the stable parts caesar
didi's concept widgets distribute
collections of basically jack jacks with
functional
operator is on den like  map a filter
when you have this capi you can
your killer feature is that the
wheelie gig for composition and maybe
products
the for stingers pipelining zo won
johanna program like this this map and
then a filter spark so in just
hang the heley  map and white stuff to
file and then filter at innax
oil pipeline system into my function
and that saves you time of day dan
movement and  actually most holding
efficient zo the way to think about this
in a few single developer homes
in close super hard to dedicate map
dat german both the things but if some
one handed dual line breda dit de sleeper
parsing stuff and then some model sunday
july width  does the filtering eat
your seamstress you can just change
gather and it will optimizer also as
those two in one of those two people
have never met and in horn over read any
any way of doing so they sting for sting
and and the seventeen in fir tassels in
memory and sharing via the cheese in spark
and john of objects you did not put oil
system that you some day i wanted us
leather high end and all delight bezie
warnaar have that car fast
de so that it was in this
version well hello the network
users will appreciate the 513 fact if
we at that stack construction there so
derksen lead to use and in this way en
and mix together lights offline praise
and ageing german you the main reason
wide open sourc  e by press home
diet coke i chose it was the frost can you
open source engine to ledger you out to
outside the actual choice abp you the
functionality
this guys vs challengers and this is where
your train tentacle
with the start udp eyes and big things like
about
sophie looking at the light breeze the
bunch of light breeze image in to spark
aan en
ex oil that will be the beam or the code the
pirate knot the core power vide that is
house within stone gauze ashely so one
for the plague by fingers on and wine
glass people they use a
mix of dan  a mix
or that stinks so 7 not 5% now is beautiful
that wine library and then the continium
color that just in china the views that
time spoke here is that that southeast
function you combine together and scala
by taj something like daan something like that you
see here  the ca  mpo voice of my
programming point-of-view thousand
details and all the things you expect
when riding software om en darth maul
execution and fish so instead of the
sample the frame look nice collision
always cfs and between each kale
because of this you can weird wines and  then
the lights up staff and and here put in the
staff and and where people's park where
my hand touches him show so that indeed
part can you can works ok the main
challenge do is dysfunctional nature or
the epa the luxury you hi larosse that
would  you well where do not start from the
beginning in teams choose or programming
the aim of cody riders be narrow and it
your color where that chopper german
that's another problem but it actually
trader of the semantics of the
cumpilation of the engine which makes
this i know the  actual real-world weather
of programming god is calling such a
library lesson efficient than it
unstable in political science the functions that
retirees the year where
a super cordial in  sight dementia
wigeri and the details so java object
something like european and there in a
super efficient one so i know dpf in the
mix in sababti moorrees
like sure you just a simple example of
this
wimps reelly comment on this is action
can you the most
comedy  show design the mailing list en
hoe de new users and among us of the
box en zo hard en zo this is people train
the target audience is so
you never early natural thing to do when
i look at dpa you've got some words and
save an  account and you can go through the
likes like i know lets met de
living room wanna dance group and key and
then some other ones for each is
theme you will be na troll and the i know that
it will give you the right answer for
this important problem is is  dat
good-bye de signature en in sparkes it
gives you a day at
hoe is something key and then a sequence of
finnish for each wali dat de signature en
john edgar who is fierce so dan capable
de executing we have actually been
al de ones  for each key to a single  e
machine en allocator giant rw
in java orphanage later once in it en
atie deed and dat can crusher machine the
worst case if it's a future i owe it can
just be really ditched and so je this is an
example where does not much weekend your
headset  we are
his extreme lee the sale ten brundel
kan je or code' and everything is guido it the
look insiders are figure old that you endure a
thousand winters and miss you more sustainable
together use with partial aggregation
so that they and example of of way
and hysterical kamal  de time and again
this might seem to pdf it's a single
person right but think about all eyes
organizational je polder to package
of the web
that thousands for support and then
you're gonna get to this particular
thing happened in you as long as the code
so that sam  dad can have that kind and
then a sugar
challenger a people help her full they
see another places as they do a
presentation zo want oh staphon
java object in-memory is test
lessons fish and then just storin  g die
arbeit java object av general these stages
turns and you know all can be who become
sheepdogs a city my god and and something like
residential houses bunch of overhead to choose a
really simple
klaas met like an austrian band shows en
de detail red and dark ltd
so user and all that hard rod is
basic about it fogg was something like that object
houses header and has carpoint as to
why the stars and the string gotcha leagues
another object in adwords is a char
array and german basically indiscreet
bid factor for a  5 about so that
kampsbaai when home from large cap
so the next karno window to so that we assign
spike and this is definitely
already out and how is the structure dps
and it so of a porn talented and
find and light of the are that yes or
composition zo in de send us a many
people have used de start jpy since mark
the dfs also they walked past the yes so pc
start u details they change old de
dh mode lebed instead of being
giovanna buxus destructoid eda which
means you have limited
set of details of the stables what you
are in strings and stuff like dat en en
viewmaster timeline starter is bernard
labor reda from decks and then on top
of there who fcp he is already there campo
ribbons basically yes cyclo gray plan  om
en derek en too much greater
optimization similar to those who can
in databases en de de coolsingel i don't
really does the program want dior
composable er die bit cryptic
optimization zo glassdoor for sepia use
oh wie translated into a logical plan
was affable 3  of basically sequel
operators and then be optimized so also want
to import from the house well and drink
there the creator physical oldtimer is the
actual
thing so long on the issue brave and
so long and thin regenerate koga of code
die thank you for your time using gardy die
so bad and the quran john doesn't change
outside handappel fatboy generating
special code that works which detail en
in this format and finally to think the
e-piano supply kind your m  my idea from
deschamps sources using some thing
called de dennis of sepia
care user will i stamp shampoo toes
frames single content 4 cnet it would be just
as popular with bcg dna frames rider on
tight epa ever that took quality
work with starter dna and then details  dat
we got married talk about to the stars
quality plant in these frames your
garden collection overhaul and you can
create did frames of anarchy that
received did so there is for hexam
politics connect the high 5 cd there
something like that so you can best know in article
too  te
ze like some of you we they go and
things can your transformations on them
like and spike wat de de francis instead
of being well and their function the
things you pass in the keshe foundation
is actually line up strong syntax pmds
all domain specific language  for
specify expressions
about so at least this is actually en
expression duitsers counter the column cold
always in the users table and check
whether it go to
california en eart  h park thousand receive
a bunch of life and cold or something in
action will be three widgetized chose and
the sting
zo ik ken axel i understand what is 3
content in a much as you go wnf you do
the things you can hang and actions
liken liken  nardini is there that computer
orizand and then
sparkler to optimize the glen looking and
all of the case in particular
in this case it might say i would only
play thing for ever often
california server so hive table is already
that partition at always
or using park em  garden index aan states
or something like that we can be just
some of the dna so trace die
colino de the poster goro time the skin barrier
never that yes whatever you were doing
knew nothing deda wat spark en finger
herald and axel i make  the sting pretty
efficient and if you did direction side
fairing burgees and who are details
so the engine can understand what
you're doing so instead of flyers en
poland group by there always find a list
of we have this concept of  enoch vocation
and then select in which a look at you
mind if you want you can make het riet
analysts both at the view on something
like and edgar sam
intellect ik je er in the more efficient
way and of course if you want to do like
this  stuff you can fall back to user
defined functions and lime
out and stuff like those horses ponies dat
had to or what you're doing is in so dsl
but who can understand it they de
frames
is de epa [ __ ] because it was already
widely used be old  if park and old
are or dvds akchaoui so the are the
based on
the ddr frame epa and ar en pain that are
pasta and one really interesting thing
about that is the previous eps
eventhough dodgers drink operation
sidetables
then you do now or the optimizations video
bicos  der italia valuer just as in
pain we now out something like lead the
staff using sticol in arcen li house to
download direction blowing there and we now
so iraqi liras the filter die and 7000
memory something like that can also be cool both side  en
beg between the color the wpa why you
know
campi the staff members and and this luxspace
ermelo harderwijk
and that other could sing builder so it
's already see much more program bold
and seek so who efteling from the new
users would use with er also there  well we
have hanger the analysts to company
for riding giant leads to page lang
sequel grays and disappears the teach them
by phone and they buy the frames so they can
be used then and that my business
stinks who exactly are dda
engineering also another standard
johanna break code to be european
here sleep zo raasdorp so under not
the structured eps week out a dollar of
cool optimizations who can do
with just a functional interface and
spark
so i have a store day in it a more
interesting response history at home so
johan by de  race and insight from we keep
task or the starks louis then creates
java object for did you film and who can
if they sprinkled quite to shape there
when candle in a week and  optimizer
garth operator same thing you risk
database we do moving joins to a
lot of this stuff like that and weak and
generate coda downtime for you
specifically along and therefore zoom or
the government is in the norm as mark you sat
the end of the day they get  something
good better performance and actually if
you can system performance english switch
language using one so so at a small
simple benchmark by
know this is for student iphone and the
east faster than scala mostly guys
the generated code who's favorite already
the virtual something called havens  com
in range of your chain a bunch of guys
from my ardie die the dpm doesn't know
what you're running nexus o dat after easter
the filter and it hester dynamically
despatched to every single records but
was you generate codec at home everything
in in  mango
so can you report and then can going
to dawn of the dead the coast guard
rocksong de staff and then the final
single show is if you won't start typing
wi  e if she him the dhcp you she prays
new to the nebel you see there that
she can have you bunch of klaas is a
range
ever javabeans and jaya view hangs
on that and you can start with the dna frame
and fell home collection  or or items
about the style and well your code stipe 7 you
can't put something got older and [ __ ]
built houses string will
soon become
djunga and typer when you are there and winnie the
operation so i'm way pushed
ardie that steel sanxenxo get back it
eda set therefore also and stability and
its stored in the official binary w and
when do things i grew by you can
still use so that same group rod
and
you still get back santing that rigid
quality calorie dondelite clasie wait
and humor fierce adze
so this is  as if you ttv simple interface
teams
so die cp eyes only came out this client
chladni 15 never did sergei mountain
what we already seen them you will i
widely and basically
crossterrein that person who caes here  ar
members survey of tony sex teen using
did frames and sequel and ocean and
stripped bridge hours in icloud
ostend dino's park platform i an
actually analyze the languages ndp ice peopl
use and we see the same thing that
love just i want a pie dan every
ne  that ever tcp jacket and then the
finals content talk about is that that
sepia is in nepal some really cool
optimizations underneath and workshop
building a bunch of new ep he is at the
table starting spark the take advantage of
this serviers idea that would be
doctor de  bar did it can actually take
part of your great and push them
door dh sorry slide park e en prix
filter the dna of avoid getting so that
something that was a purple ball with the
private sep yes your ex and at brass chrome
buster import format in  ariely
complicated wnf isam machine learning
pipeline zagreb frame is bizarre
advanced analytics sepia are build on
each end and the wangdda eltako bardolino
bit
is the ham is treats mood which  is
a high-level
mood hey edgar deadly started
building largeur based on an
based on day the frames om zo
station screaming basic lisa high-level
streaming napier it support vs chance of
advanced breaks in features like
in venray window kept going a lot of
operations and sections  and things like
to
and the between design between pot and toe
and continuous aplication so operational
aplication so for hey sample your iphone
talking you put yourself in the hardest
thing is getting you streaming system
like always storm the talk to storage
media sorry you chicken  tacos what your
skin from the import and hotel il pozzo that
image and concept instructor gaming app
here's the details about your hp title
hopping
aroma master of people often
man hands simcoe dan bad guys how and
when i' parkways the men through the
cities or the steam and weekend you
want to take a shower afterwards hi the final long harbor square
cd definitely built-in
on concept or can it be restyled pick up
a patch the c  ode or add some new
operations week and axel i start from where
it left off and let you actually be
handled application without having to
remember
around lunchtime the willy to singapore
the do not wanna talk about you is that jp
so basically dpa is super simple and  kids
on
mostar the mood hepie he sat there those
choices just ingram analyzing and
existing region had zo is haven-bad step
die computer something and its own
shadow operators understood by starck
permission to you can just take it and
turn it into an income and  i'm just
keeps department that's always about pain
so in this case wim card
ow when shed mg sunday do group at
by using the powerstore invite
my old for 3d in it stuff like there
and computers latency
and heart out in sd and that this  is a
batch kabira mindset gryce de we dance
events can you wanna make a the streaming
dram
we so change the input and output sorry c
who stream and high-stream
at the computation in vienna silent so 1
e  n 2 and 3 rounds sparco would be mine
clique arno hanging in an incremental
know so basically it takes the old gray
binary transforms into something and
calm and also with care for new file
are four time
how you actually case beasts criticism the
old suitcase of the  targets and add in the
new was and who weit out who keeps
part-timers light output the park eo where
preparation and and who make-up that
transaction halal they are basically the
moment who see some fine ass die de the
moment who commit
der is already  two types of taiko a case that
was francois die zo weekend doe vote
you to get d pierrot disappear
and the om your is a this is possible for
spark and hard for something like i
know if you may know
it makes me producer something is
b  -choice
week and support the cement x or the
competition anyway
this is a actually gino this is a
cool by on this expression in the en and
frames and so thin weekend figure out how
to design and cream and oil holy see you
know this is loading so that collins from
parquet hear this is partitioning were
studio in output can also be something really
cool feature or dpr then all lobith
stardoll to take as with des and
something warm and some search side that
chose now and i think as on  table the
xenon machine learning graff for
you doing it comb pole tough square
that weekend came analyzed and i can
just doing ankle and oil you
can boil it
so this is the system that oil has been
stuffy since the and deaf  en beesten
clients last year we have already a
bunch of like really cool
use cases en vet including johan d
there nothing pipeline from this sermon sorry
wie just be running this in production
and en dan die we have a wide variety of
the point en en  barroso companies like
fire come and tight eyes have already
being said you won't find out more about
it has a large of tax aan
eine buddha bar dipsaus linate this model
of income analyzing actually works
en en de fin  already finger wanna talk about
is so new research spyderco wild from
my group is an in stanford and so
this is who search' where he sings the
first janet there is a really
interesting marjoleine joyce den this
camp our buttocks that ideal something to
interim hr  for a new ways of riding
software
so basically the motivation for world is
that if you look out of the wreath in hardware
jeuj machine guests single cervelaat tab
is there the study out system all noise
and memory is scanning the new age
dfs or a  in salty memory ben
uit de reed basic leave you look at what
people actually compute
in detail intensive applications most of
the things you come pewds it seems
linear keep you bar staff for sea colino
selecting sometimes a gaydar
ja basically memory by reading and
harding bytes van  memory is much slower
than just running the cycles the computer
sticks both this means is in and the
stranger can tering basic je de rate
which i get cycles a flap say whatever
is much higher than the white witch
memory bandwidth is increasing
zou der duits resistance huis ned's been
happening actually this means is that the
traditional way of composing library
of a single machine can be extremely
inefficient
and this corner de come up with much better
ways of  drink
zo is the traditional way campolife bv
know why you just about any
programming languages is function god zo in fu
ction allows the wider function and b
sically it takes a simpoints some point
home the staff german in-memory that is audib
e coming out and then it  this
camp youtube stuff in our takes you
might also produces a bar for with all
the output and memory and it gives
you back pointer te there zo
uw nationale interface en wan pipel redesigning the
sting china
reload en stones de memory cabinet construction
like to to instructions zo  hot was
super cheap so like of costigan at
design step so who the they do this
lodge and store scan closet hangers
obstacles win j  e highlighter will 2-stroke
oil everyone textilia bubble sort jesus
super simple example or
here also a dull ache that address
calling pandas in mumbai
you you just wanna calf idea of
ons at parnassia panache doctor de an
eva liaison and computer more and when
oney get  in major you have all
you did a memory
one you can't possibly a csweert it
scans all further thai folio cover
of ecodorpen 9000 ghent and finally your
computer more so combat adjust kings
de detail once and out for the number
this is that see  je te bout for 5 times
will be cause irska wished to review
scandlines te right then i read this
card and the white uitkijk-den uw ii
desu ka
zo this is basic 4:57 scans de memory
where experienced dan there do with lower than
what  this function site 3
zoë gun is in the ladder frameworks of
this frame oishi and who function i
used within incizo economist at a pen
that all the functions a heavily optimize is
a like the pain talent europe greeting
y  ou can get velar's lola see who
measure between 5 and sturdy ex
if you have all ride location that campo
black features and this is ironic we
can have significant problem dikes
weekend xpect de
arthur of every single line width he is
called the compiler lightwood and spark like
ie well nam fits there is a god who
thousands of functions in detail the compiler are
clear all the once a happy wok
together and generates efficient short
something like it in it's definitely i can you
already i now i can get there in no time who
drinks the city are so  in the world
are in this time so common high
time you can think of it in some beautiful
site
michael jpam or something like that but
for da paolo code that that you optimize her name
and basically what your goal is
you have you definitely engaged functions
and they could be running peace of
times of computing outside they all map
so computing and combing through
intermediate presentation or which is
de wal die hard en displays a similar
role do  odziek ological klein his trip
showdance park where it's a bit more
general quite simple it supports next to the
loops and stuff like to that je then no
in siebel
and danny optimized and after i see the
bits of work to be done
bij fj library optimize and i  actually
generative is a code for the fun times
of powell hydroxy walser tiger in
portability and carhartt work in the
tiger
and if so basically this is a wheelie in
ice tray for users to heart to
accelerate al die library chose all those
covers doe is map
something  function at it yourself into this
tiger and then why do flybridge you
combine will get camp aalten kat and
did not do too little compiler die
even so this app works so i am at 3f
filippi look at this in terms of its be
one thing you can  locate te compared
with this stuff like to do hope en
cialis wel zo box eps oh oh zo hardware
and pen ntp eyes but they don't have
this competition aspects eagle that
evolves and two via for us open cl
inari-taisha  cornel
and die gencer to that end librarything the
death knight sweating
the get them to share dat cumpilation so
so of the hoist will both bolts
contents of the details of des saveurs
so the dog aimée ph that's actually
really simple the media is so lazy
evaluation
so as your  calling the nebo light
breeze and left point of the common
light breeze
this mid snippets of all your coach
the hangtime and the dog and fields be
then read song so these seperate functions
the most beautiful foundation
otherwise it just team members die
snippets of  cold and then you win tablet
actually evaluate the dog and will
combine these into one program and
optimize and just the hunger games de
same in memory dah dah dah dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah in the begin ik zo
week and archer liang for instance  to
umpire being lines park sequels
in memory for met without changing and the
kon fingers so composition workshop
glassline base here from people for to
voor met kan him der kooi dare  t de maize
together
and the brush programming languages and all k
nds of town hall lang is that always curre
t in this way so th
t the for stijn or you that yes is on and and t
erefore also a kia have the irm zoey v sma
l but powerful language for hp be
in the die scampi t-shirt out in
nepal slice of
artefacts my sisters and so basically
so tube concepts and down that's why
why so it is not really small one death
paulo de groups which has to go over
adrz in taal en everything and well this
actually paulo bij the vote on and then
der bilder switch on a budget for
producing gray zat zo builder would
lobith like the actual leder is a
spark of 15
stuff like therefore these map pages can
basically be the rogue's where you can model
results and they can produce  something
from the and
and third of thai for example these
bilderdam
tags and elements and produces a list
with all of them
the sun that computers together and the
coolsingel booties can implement wim decleir the vision
eat va  n lian
de of hardware shiner jpu for example
computing' to some might be a giant
aggregation critic to that end there would be
cage sand at the cpu in my digital
local singa not score sorry here
the changer releases program to care and the
irm android really small tits kwai
jungle so hot cando relational holder
barlingen manageable functional
one he would spark and if we don't we
younes pace voice
sits so the couple of example where
to give us and unjust can
implementing functional operators using
wilders is there for close when
implements map
so  to do map we create this web
builder widgets de wanda just op enzymes
de produced a list and then i have paulo
wore them for i tried him in the did we
never
and for wax in the builder de to push
arnhem en den bliek everything they  wanted
is have those steering functions mortgage and
result
now all the finalizing move and i have
sauce worked in salt
so that ponies and forests map is so the
magnifying
glass this salt ok k  om en dennen
second example is reviews sorry this is
actually stimuli simpler johnny de
france is a cello smoothing stuff in
to do list in modern too close other
typo builder that computer and a social
function
sorry dat scout motor and danley just go
cda and monuments this  and get there is
also give us also just download a giant
and shop single reflection
the codes 2 is you can also expressway
investing from
reviews and between them and getting
things and actually sparks compiler for
a shampoo that's a deal
so pretty simple suppose that i  have peace
over dna and your 3 both a map and 3 djoez
over de cm import dna where i you wanna
computer are the graphics number and
joanna computer some of you were just
trying the magnifying glass in syria die the single
look for you say hey
output gino  classico ons whatever en in
sport output to
classico des partis je rimini 4 zings
trail is parsi came so now operator
die submarines map and the reviews man press
in which were you can a  ctually is all that
expert stage coast has your builders and
in this appeal to deposit build is
zo this is really simple example of
optimization week and east that hard
rod light lube styling gray
via nestle oops i break name in the blog
staff the me is  the candle hierarchy
and awakened wise their ancient city seems that
so redesigned there in between gate that is
willie clow devil compiler
optimizations that you minimize did
poverty brings german german take or the
game a modern harder so that brief
introduction to mount
both the networks so and  so there is to the
ministry that friends dear nephew so
choose a single framework at the self
like name tyrells can enable
suffer and speed-ups graphic and every
application is calling 1000 of the
function case no no one just might and
application that uitzend vector  is and
stars so
really good example of that is an amp is
so nam by users blows for aids
operations earphones praying them
optimized and repeat your couch is so  if
you doing something like having two
factors duits kan be superfast you
never gonna beat them but if you doing
something like adding form factors well
you knew function that takes into
inputs and producers walnut
sorry vehemently all those things times en
nou here matter leising this is  as a
memory vitens and a cyclist views
rector you can have that you can demolish in
this case by generate a function
that actually and twelve or there must be on
this you can pass by do you know the parts
who if on leaders in sparks nicholas
sparks iquality at home  operator views and
kind him a benefit's here
they offered five or six ex benefit is
iphone
generating pretty efficient code beacause
regenerate vector rise like assembly
code and jos trainer more intense for so
arrangement song and his wife
just recently added the compiler for the
separators for hey say  you the sea breeze
and is this compiler callexcell no there
takes the basic linear autobar breeders
and views them into some  thing and fish
and the gods
otherwise i know i via
Dezeben in excisting month and then why you
combine light breeze
you can get for your speed ups by
combining him so this is a simple
pandas in mumbai becomes so penders in
mumbai
actually implements operator in c was
that urethra anyway der wet after that
slovak let begin with by real
workflows tents combine let your weapon
riders and  this is to a fun toy
so basically wi-fi catch you is in free
use world with no car fly-by
optimizations week en de bouwdefective of
nine speed up over something in in this work
for detail and then if you enable chance
library optimizations  week and avoider
via expeed up and then the final thingys
world the code net
is already explicit ran from eyecatcher in
a you can door sequential runs it
is with the two  combing so in super
easy to hang well
anne multi-core jpu by kenzo what you can
do is count as longer flybridge experts
in a pole wow week and joss
stone age restore in this case week and
maybe can just turn on the multi-core
jaw and
and kan another factor of ten speed up
by way so that german simple
example on this project i still super
wil nobody afraid it is open source and
realized it up with people who every
when traject like they use the slide
brisa lite
or maybe  a developing a library and wine
for sale generated by can tell you have
to work in a and c de kool generator'
voor spark en die using this this is
risks users to each operator with
yourself and wout combines or something like
the saxon poetry and  the
cheeks direction again open source caesar
integration with at
die switches so this package kalk
grizzly is investor mountain
than one day a few blocks should ever be
simpler of why and then
in any case german as open source weeke  nd
equipment lyon die arbeit who becomes
live feedback and and impotent there is hi
tutorial makes where a man thinks it is like this
cruiser i know developers and
anyone mining software is products at
composing
existing library is so you
think we think this happens
and dirk settings  thing where it's exciting
and view researcher mebius to i said
celebrate things practitioner is that the
hardware trends less
all the way of the race who keeps
software and the plague and library balance
site in all day three hundreds of
millions of lines of code
arno longer and  fashion that mother
hardware that choice d there had to be my
ministers and teacher
upcoming highlight fps ogp use that for
that speed up the parsing this is not
gonna get so now magic in memory
that is along act of that faster because
so anywhere from costumes down  to one
knows you can get these fields speed-ups
by deling wit en and with that the trend sets
the champ i think the sinner parties en
die spark en spark se  quel en while they
just a few examples of services of these
innovations brings so can there beer like
my love to see
ik zag die word is breakdown en and how
we can make session of berg
tanks
yes happy to take a question sublime
essence
oh this while  other things you need is
you were looking to learn more about
spark we have giant event coming out de
mars conisch en er in de markt so in
love to see you there
oh so yes cherishes yes sorry want you
debt machine lenny en de graph
king indra  they come after year oh yes yes
well what is t
buddhist a coach and giveaways
jamaica
jeanneau prestige single via me zo ow hi
chewy door bent of stuff for samsung
reaction vector a is the code that even
beacause avm doesn't always did and then
be  colloquium she this is a hardware and
the pennant went through emotion tyler and
exedy pieces about
and the plenty of tassel is that we did not
explicitly get the crown yes
were similar to buy aunt julia once
wanted a new long yes a n  euwe long
tinkering yes is the fernandez solar
denpasar syntax dextro syntax only
om
messi and because it meant to be
generated by library sweetie my single
fits all i do like a functional and with
like ml shipping seems there and action
that will try i would a monkey  and here
sustainable built-in already your reaction
when there are seamstresses in texas dust
is a la de fork touring rider your club
arthur and it's not really research so i
have invested you just yes yes
this is a really excellent low glare
my recent blogs by questions  or an
application you find my god escape the
applicable to large
in a fir monasteries mean so down to
personal computer uprising mee and in a
lesson for kiev working in
in engine on the sunlight anders en ik
wil your vision for application of this
is
ja zo  yes basically yes duh review essence
while i think this can be such a festival
anyone working with tim sign pen die
are numpy van anne single machina in
the always wanted to b  e faster
and this is a much easier way for
developers of those we brieste get high
performing speakers are they derksen
leading lady optimize the function and
de olie next place your cancer
optimizations guys from shell and this is
a week before you silent can your why this
function seperately
in this function online version house
next to supergirl bennet
i like it was my choice in fact they
change nicer than my things in sea and
you get some good performance so
great thing would like those good en
center for each library' toe adapter
just got  better performance arnhem
article hi just to be able to sdp user
whatever
and then we teinten designer in
leeuwarden more people adapter the tomorrow
of network in fact de huis today
intense of concrete think you can eat out
for door imam in german knights of the
light of  light breeze and only thing
that we think will be really great for
is if you wanna bill the machine learning
maar dollar pipeline en dunster more
than a mobi  le phone or something like
that sowjet-unie fast car and this two
parts of die came partis
tess magnificient taking all the rods
in pain that his arm mumbai and
megatron
appreciation is the phone hardware venders
actually be live crazy chip sunday die
just for them and  they say ho'
info neapel occasions gifts that that
would be great barbie around when your
dearest bacon because it a great sick so
this is a week before dente does out of
both gaming reviews family young salvia
who can offer the winter
lvm for paal al codello  via met selfies
great for sequential stuff but it
doesn't have concepts like a
parallel that we run the nepal so can you often
term yes yes anyway reason why this looks
like iphone stars force kalahari
mouris is a fix in tarjay 7000 look
like en  will you be raeckse relaxed
oak yes where this if yes aydin cedar cool
things where so enter her home
where she these another cool thing that
are
ria zoey zoey cheeks terweijde  te bv you
see the cult of nederkouter
identification
the harder force prototype vet in scala
which work to really great for spark hey
guys grateful dead but but one ear spy
stand in it was super on a photo lunch
rivm and again few seconds so the like on
your mom of function of anyway so in the
house well and the models de lang widgets
11 is correct its own language
yes yes
[Music]
oh thank you mom sahar from facebook oh it
's village germ in the frying
as the wind casey is already white there seemed  a
lesson slide the more like beeping revision
a thick 3 dvd's and octoral pepper and
so already the website with box and
tutorials and step so just look at
basically the german and before
who sends it and so this kind of pepper and
thunder
yes  hear yes and real after a minus
if i wondered why you're very close to
facebook housewife are another such content
people the student ruby's the
project leader de just buy gift voucher
that
las crush en yes
book search
jane expectations lasts for hours
clinical get up there may be like i
have never wants fellow party member the high
violet
high gloss there counted smarter in two hearts
side there still imax said the building the
building so
emperor research project for the neck
serious beko cellphone amazing platform
to do research on how to  optimize
disco de houwdoe when new
hardware so word and a continuous cucina
just a charge
i know integration its sparkler light
breeze ben the heart the timing in club i
really cool if i know people dreamcoat
generation time there and there some
interesting and for i like  for instance
pain thousand your is coming out hi like this
preferably
the developer at nasa stardust thinking
about that some may be act you can
put now who stuck bastards people so bad
there is so hard language
barbie de think i know if you can ever
put  we in using lvm to generate code
and new car local let me have a
this kind of biological so who sings this
and entry point der yes yes and it so sorry
tiny part  ner drive and cda at this said
i want to see here if people hanger hook
it up how you worked really hard to make
the language be malmedy sit
hapte maisto
why it's not a daunting lighting for
developers the sauce if matter
spark from the begining lots  of people
glider just because they said ouali in
the worst-case
i an understand is codebase and
maintain it myself if these guys korea
doing with a link-o-loon external
functions like in sheer santing there
is or x-press in the dan must  -ie ya know
you can call external functions and
three times a week en we've got the
functions and also would think i love
just make i al die him you first
class and so you can just powder
lvm dood van marjo steffen de oldies
interesting things that take like stay
by young line thousand under mentally already
through with stuff like came home zoé me
doe deed is yes this time so whose word
can you tides two lvm in the future such a
weekend you something as the generate
coach for  for for other platforms
yes what is the big thing gray samsung
fancy rust optimize with them like you
will never
design the review hp
semblance actions of whatever anyway
strongedge had him yes